who should play the man who's saying
babalu
wokesters think they know better than
you
wow
writer director aaron circuit is
defending his casting of javier bartom
as a cuban character in his new film
being the ricardo's apparently some
people had a problem that bartom who's
spanish was tapped to play desi arnaz
who's cuban in an interview with the
uk's sunday time sorkin called casting
based on race or sexual orientation the
mother of all empty gestures he argues
that in doing so it's just the artistic
community re-segregating itself adding
quote
nouns aren't actable gay and straight
aren't actable you can act being
attracted to someone but can't add k or
straight so this notion that only gay
actors should play gay characters that
that only a cuban actor should play desi
honestly i think it's the mother of all
empty gestures and a bad idea
excuse me you mean birthing person of
all empty gestures the disgusting
transphobe i think this segment is over
you know guy go to you for no reason at
all uh when you see straight actors
playing gay characters or vice versa
does it bother you thank you for the
random question greg yes um
not really no the only thing that
bothers me is there are a lot of gay
actors
right and i see all of them on instagram
like trying to get attention there it's
like aaron please cast them and just
take them away to something real um but
no i think that this is this whole game
that is played is tedious right it's
like if you are not exactly the right
type of person then you can't do this
because representation and equity and
all of that
i think it's exhausting to most people
it's this very inside game within world
culture and like wow i'm all here for
like based aaron sorkin i was not
expecting this from him
defended gina carano is that we should
just be able to get offended sometimes
like red pill what happened to this guy
yeah i'm about it yeah yeah it's
probably because it's getting harder and
harder to cast for his stuff and he also
likes actors and actresses who are good
yeah are good and he can't use them like
jeff daniels i mean he wants but you
know you know what uh uh it's the whole
point about susan is
susan is about about acting is that you
should play people that are unlike who
you are because that shows your merit as
an actor for example i know
i would be a great black female lesbian
i would i would knock it out of the park
you would thank you you would you would
do very well i've been studying it
i have so look okay so aaron sorkin says
the best talent should win out right yes
you don't have to be cuban to play desi
so
that means somebody like me
could play snow white would that be fair
i think so absolutely
african american can play cinderella but
are you a good actress
uh that would require some work um
so i could get better you know i'm a
business girl and lots of numbers going
through my head but yes i just think
that those minorities in hollywood they
don't get enough opportunities and i
think they should get more roles well
you know what what if you know the fact
is though it's like you can't well
anyway i'm not gonna argue with you
uh about this joe uh i like the phrase
actable i've never heard that phrase
before yeah it's like lunchables yes oh
yeah nice the most underrated snack
sometimes you know people gave it a bad
rap because it wasn't healthy but you
could do you could put a mean little
cracker sandwich out of that it worked
in a pinch yeah yeah i'm surprised
people uh are so mad they didn't know
his original plan was to have javier
bread and play lucy
what's funny is like half of our
audience doesn't even know what i love
lucy is right you i mean you you're 70.
yes um i'm you know i'm in my low 40s
but
not that funny
i could be you know i look pretty good
for my age
people on the other hand a disaster
yeah people are not mentioning nicole
kidman's australian yes
this this is that's why it's called
acting and she played the wife of tom
cruise that a lot of acting
yeah thank you yeah if you think this is
a beard
so
yeah this is why it's so absurd that
acting now what is it is is he supposed
to become an alcoholic now to play desi
arnaz does your name lost an alcoholic
you're supposed to pretend that's and i
don't like that and i really don't like
the way actors who are beautiful try to
claim extra credit when they play busted
people like when charlize looked through
played um
ugly people they're the world is full of
ugly people and you don't have to put it
on the screen
oh i'm gonna i'm not gonna wear any
makeup yeah we don't need that we
already have that so yeah yeah i want
you to actors if you're going to play a
serial killer make it a hot one you
don't have to go ugly to just like oh
i'm going to make myself look like
warnos or whatever the person was yeah
you don't have to do that
cash
do you feel like you're watching a lot
of liberals doing battle with the
frankenstein monster they created it
wasn't like aaron sorkins aaron sorkin
has done a lot to create this
politically this pc environment for
decades yeah i mean that's exactly what
they're doing they're also not watching
enough bollywood so if they started
doing that we'd have a solution but to
take it back to what susan was saying
you know what infuriates me nothing
about you know we got to get more
minority actors in there or the right
gay actors you know i turn on all these
films and i see a brown guy being played
by a non-brown guy there's like a
billion of us on planet earth you can
you can freaking find one like employ us
yes and you could vouch for me and get
me in one of these i definitely am it's
either that or they hire justin trudeau
right that's nice yeah thank you look at
his range yeah he could do anything or
he could just play one role as long as
there's some paint nearby
racist
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else